we ready what's happening you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey here I wanted
dead or alive night on Instagram live
you understand me we got a couple things
to talk about first of all thank you for
all the overwhelming support and the
love I ain't no angel but I ain't no
[ __ ] saint either whatever
but you guys know where my heart is at
all times and whatnot I want to thank
the church family you know whoever
listens to JRE who's got our back thank
you very much for starters we ain't
going nowhere
well let's get down to business here
number one I want to thank the ladies of
comedy who were taking a stand I am not
mad at you at all it's gotten out of
control you guys have heard different
things so I cannot be mad at you I
encourage you to keep on your stand
you call him people that I've taken on
the road to find out dirt whether I do
drugs or whatever that I don't
understand the calls from the other
little comics or the call on the ground
and torture and women that I've known
personally that I don't understand you
know listen you're on a podcast you
talking [ __ ] you're in the [ __ ] eat
at a moment you know nobody knows until
you in the podcast and you trying to be
funny that podcast is take in 2010
before we knew podcast we're gonna go
anywhere who the [ __ ] knew they were
gonna go anywhere
so I tell a story on a podcast now when
I got into podcasting what happened was
we went on that we thought it was radio
and one day I told the story about
mugging a hooking light no wig on fire
and next thing you know I got a rise I
got a reaction I got a reaction because
I was telling the truth about something
that people don't usually talk about I
don't give a [ __ ] I grew up in North
Bergen New Jersey northern New Jersey
New York and we went out at night I got
a [ __ ] life but on the other hand
let's start from the beginning
I was raised by a single mom she was hot
she had a bomb if you know all these
stories this is for you women who would
take understand if you know anything
about my mom my mom died with an alias
because when she was in Cuba she went to
a dance with her little sister and the
guy took my little my aunt Rosita who's
still alive in Cuba and was raping her
and my mother stuck up for him and
stabbed a guy with a bottle and the guy
died and she had to come here under an
alias so for all you women who go to
yoga and kickboxing go [ __ ] yourself
okay that's what you do right there
that's how you stop this [ __ ] number two
I was raised in the house to respect and
love women now let's get back again to
the beginning Richard Pryor was the guy
that opened up my world to comedy but it
was until I read this book by [ __ ]
Lenny Bruce ladies and gentlemen I
decided that's what I wanted my life to
be and it's like I told my wife the
other night when I had to sit her down
and explain what the [ __ ] was going on
when I read that book you know what this
book is about Lenny Bruce his [ __ ]
ladies and gentlemen about him living
after Chelsea him doing stand-up with
strippers and doing heroin with jazz
musicians and waking up at 2:00 in the
afternoon and then he had a fight for
his [ __ ] rights to say what the [ __ ]
was saying on stage today and on these
[ __ ] podcasts they would throw you in
jail and this [ __ ] was out so
when I read that that let me know what I
wanted to do I wanted to do everyone and
get my [ __ ] dick sucked okay I was a
loser I had nothing else going I just
come out of [ __ ] prison
and this was my only option so I went
with it I did not expect [ __ ] success
or LA I thought it would be a [ __ ]
big comic on the road living from week
to week like Doug Stanhope I didn't give
a [ __ ] that's what I wanted I got a deal
I moved to LA and next you know I'm like
this world famous [ __ ] comedy store
and I'm overwhelmed and after a few
months I see this type that you know
it's just a different [ __ ] world
nothing like I grew up
but not I grew up around people who were
real people who [ __ ] looked at you in
the eye when they talk to you I didn't
grow up around this [ __ ] so I got
presented at The Comedy Store you know I
met my friends down there and the rest
is [ __ ] history one night there's a
girl down there in 97 I knew her I knew
her very well she had been lurking
around there and she wanted stage time
or whatever and it was one two she asked
me I would suck your dick I thought it
was a [ __ ] joke I even walked into
the payphone that used to be at the
bottom of the original and may believe I
was called a Mickey and hung up the
phone and listen it was a mistake then I
knew it
whatever I talked about it now you guys
want to get mad at a guy for laughing I
don't know I don't know what law and
order you [ __ ] watch but they never
arrested nobody for something laughing
okay and there's nothing in the
Constitution that gets you in trouble
for laughing we laugh I see a guy in the
wheelchair fall I laugh that's my crazy
sense of humor so everybody has a
different sense of humor
you [ __ ] listen to SNL and oh
my god go [ __ ] yourself they never said
a funny [ __ ] thing but now you want
to [ __ ] attack this new style of
[ __ ] comedy now I'm not responsible
for what anybody else did I'm
responsible for my actions what you
[ __ ] wanted me to do was to
come here and stand here with three
black people and two women to prove I
need to prove nothing the allegations
were on me there's no allegations
there's no nothing I told the truth now
for 20 years you [ __ ] been saying
I'm a liar so what about the guy who
pumped in the iron boulder you don't
care about him what about the guy threw
in the trunk of a car and [ __ ] bolted
I went to jail for and did my time I did
my [ __ ] time so who the [ __ ] are you
to be the judge the jury and the
executioner you have no right to Witter
or whoever the [ __ ] you are so go [ __ ]
yourself that's the status nobody ever
gave you the right to be the judge the
jury nobody I don't know who the [ __ ]
you think you are I faced the judge I
did my time like a man I came out and I
decided on this greasy [ __ ] business
you understand me and that's just the
[ __ ] way it is now you can't arrest a
guy for laughs and the throwing him
under the bus so whatever you left who
gives a [ __ ] what do you know if after
that podcast that gentleman didn't pull
me aside and say hey what you saw on the
podcast was wrong do you guys know if he
did that
did you ask did you know you didn't you
just went with whatever the [ __ ] you
whatever wanted to think so
it it's plain and simple call everybody
you want reach out to whoever you want
I've been with my wife since July first
we're gonna celebrate 20 years I've had
no problems none at all we have a
beautiful child one night Lee and I went
to do a gig Pasadena something like that
around the drive back I was telling Lee
I just went into a a thing about the
years on the road you know doing triple
runs and and I was just telling them
stories of the things I had seen and we
got a cop on my house and we kept
talking and the next thing you know my
body was shaken from the things I had
seen on the road the things I had done
the craziness I had been involved with
was any of it wrong oh yeah I got into a
fight in Idaho you know the whole
[ __ ] deal but listen that's what
being a comic is about you guys made us
to be something we weren't when I got
into comedy I wanted to be Lenny Bruce I
didn't want to be bothered I didn't want
I didn't I wanted to [ __ ] say
whatever the [ __ ] I want to say and
guess what till today I said whatever
the [ __ ] I want to say I don't give a
[ __ ] I've been as honest as I can with
you [ __ ] since day one about my
life and right away you want to use it
against me and get me wrong listen when
that [ __ ] judge from the Supreme
Court District two years ago remember he
choked the [ __ ] white chick in
college with the four [ __ ] eyes
whatever the [ __ ] right there when I saw
that I set the [ __ ] egg timer on I
knew would be a matter of time before
somebody watched a video on raised a ham
and guess what if I I've told everything
I've done
so and I've done that for a reason to
show people that what they feed you in
society what you [ __ ] are
against is [ __ ] you do what the [ __ ]
your heart calls for or you've got all
these guidance counselor should be shot
home they [ __ ] sold you on out and
the thing for you to make money I never
so John what to be happy when I started
to church what's happening now I started
and I wanted to be as honest as I could
about my past to let you [ __ ]
know what you could do with your life
with the assets that you have I'm a
[ __ ] loser bum with no parents
I got a GED what the [ __ ] in prison I'm
CUBAN I got all the X's on me you could
ask for but that didn't stop me and I
want to let you know as Americans that
that shouldn't stop you either
shouldn't [ __ ] stop you either who
gives a [ __ ] well then you get out of
prison they ask you if you want to go on
disability because you're never gonna
get a job as a felon do you think I
signed that paperwork I don't to shove
it up their [ __ ] ass and every time
after that when I apply for a job and
they say have you gotten a felony I put
no and then they call me and after a
week and they say listen you came up you
lied to it no I didn't my name is Jose
[ __ ] Diaz is a million of us good
luck finding [ __ ] whatever they made
a mistake they judge me on that week of
work and my character and they continue
letting me work there so hey whatever
the [ __ ] you want to say guess what
I've died three times I died when I
found my mother on the floor I died when
I'm [ __ ] I went to [ __ ] prison and
I died in 1991 when I went to with the
voice and let me tell you something I'm
[ __ ] I live for this [ __ ] I live for
this [ __ ] this is what I'm made of
I'm American I don't [ __ ] give up cuz
you [ __ ] there's one meter I don't
give up I'm not gonna give up I'm gonna
keep doing what I'm doing I'm gonna keep
telling crazy stories and if you don't
like that one I'll tell you another one
you understand me cuz that's what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about you you're not
gonna stop the laughter yeah some comics
did some bad things they've been accused
whatever nobody accused me I told you
[ __ ] what I did so what are you
you know you have nowhere to go
so keep calling all the comics you want
contact the waitresses at the store
contact the comedy club owners ask him
what my behavior has been like the last
thing is you know 13 years ago I got
[ __ ] clean off cocaine I changed a
lot but as I was telling you that night
would lead this must have happened seven
years ago six years ago after I told Leo
all those [ __ ] horrific stories about
what I had seen on the road and check
shooting heroin and you know I went
upstairs and did the only thing I could
do is to be a better father to teach my
daughter to never be in that position to
never go up to a man and say I'll trade
off something with you for you people
who said coercion are you [ __ ]
kidding me again when was the last time
you watched an episode of Law & Order
coercion there was no coercion obviously
you do not know what goes on in
Hollywood yeah there's a lot of bad guys
out there but there's a lot a lot of
women with bad intentions out there
no names I don't have to name names when
I blow nobody under the bus here I'm
just telling you a reality of this
[ __ ] game
so if you're looking to cancel
[ __ ] you're barking up the wrong
tree
I got felonies I slept on a rocket ship
and I was poor and homeless I bounced
back from that so nothing you could do
could [ __ ] stop me so I love you
[ __ ] to death I'm not going
nowhere I'm a smoke please join me and
finish up here real quick I love you
guys I respect you the people who
supported me barstool sports you bad
[ __ ] Legion of skanks
you bad [ __ ] Sickler or you
[ __ ] podcast that had my [ __ ] back
one by one I seen who you are and you
know where my artist my heart has always
been on my [ __ ] sleeve I help people
I've always [ __ ] help how many women
listen I heard a rumor years ago that
women were upset cuz they weren't
getting spots at the [ __ ] store okay
nothing I could do about that guys
nothing I could
we do about that but there was something
I could do I could put women on my
podcast
I have 800 podcast there's probably been
a hundred women on my podcast start with
them ask them about how I treated them
nobody saw the episode 170 on I hate the
[ __ ] bed alone pastor on the couch I
could have [ __ ] jumped up and down on
Sarah Tiana did I no no no so start with
them start with a hundred [ __ ] women
I put on this podcast to give light to
and to treat him like a [ __ ]
gentleman and whatever they [ __ ] need
there's been tons of them I guess silly
and drop names but [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you don't deserve their names because
they're a lot better than you [ __ ]
dirty [ __ ] that are out there calling
each other up let us know what he did
what the [ __ ] kind of [ __ ] is that
you know what I did I just [ __ ] told
you ok listen there was some story is a
comedy story is comedy and exaggeration
okay
let's [ __ ] look at the [ __ ] sexy
okay
I never hosted it too valuable
I never hosted the belly room I was a
host in the original room I hadn't
looked down at the [ __ ] belly room in
because mitzi made me a regular after a
month I'm not gonna lie to you so I
didn't go up to that [ __ ] belly room
I was scared of a [ __ ] ghost I was in
the original room Oh Joey how can you
miss that fact because I was involved in
a [ __ ] story joy but you said you
made a do it 2010 oh no no I said 20
times yes but I meant to say 20 people
or whatever the [ __ ] that who knows what
the [ __ ] you saying you're in the heat
of passion again I'm not backpedaling
I'm just telling you [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] it is to be behind there
again this happened 24 years ago and the
story was told ten years ago way before
my daughter was born anything like that
so now what do I do now
what the [ __ ] do you want me to do now
you want me to go hide under a rock
that's what a [ __ ] does me I'm a
second-generation [ __ ]
first-generation Cuban Cuban
revolutionaries are the toughest
[ __ ] you ever want to go
against you wanna battle you go up
against a [ __ ] Cuban who came over in
1959 oh yay they're gonna let go or not
door wiow you get to get you [ __ ] with
us will [ __ ] with we no we wrote the
book on revolution this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's going on here guess what I live
for this [ __ ] because I've been facing
accusations all my life which I put upon
myself when I was a thief and a burglar
and a junkie I put myself in horrible
situations but I will tell you one thing
Tommy was my [ __ ] religion this is
day one I've been a comic you guys
accusing my buddy a [ __ ] whatever
that man has more class than any of you
[ __ ] I've ever seen in my life
that man has bought me more steaks and
took care of me
he hates drugs he carried me for years
because he saw what the [ __ ] was inside
of me he knew I was just struggling
I had [ __ ] dark [ __ ] ghosts
whatever you call him skeletons and I
still got skeletons but I check on him
and I try to make them better why don't
you guys break up the guy kidnapped
that's one of the most hey that's 48
years in prison you guys didn't never
bring that up well what did I do I had
him on the show I respected him he came
to my show a couple of the things I did
to make up for my wrongs for the longest
time I've been trying to make up for my
[ __ ] wrongs I've called people I've
apologized to people I've done
everything I can to be wrong I've sent
some people money there's some people
you can't apologize to get him saying it
was that [ __ ] up who is a long time
ago or they just don't want to hear it
but that's the mission and the crusade
I've been on since day one listen I'm no
[ __ ] star I'm no big star
I'm very fortunate to have and do the
things I've done till today you want to
take those away go ahead you could take
them away but you can't take away the
work I put in you can't take away my
balls you can't take away my heart you
can't take away my soul that's what you
go on up the war against what are they
even gonna have a war there's nothing
I told you what happened and now either
you move on with your [ __ ] life
go jump up and down at a [ __ ] parade
or you could keep picking at that
[ __ ] bees hive and nothing's gonna go
your way move on with your life if you
want to end the laughter go [ __ ] pick
on somebody the [ __ ] else
I'm Joey [ __ ] Coco Diaz the
church or what's happened now Mondays on
Wednesdays
don't forget [ __ ] Spotify understand
me and I'm gonna be doing these a couple
nights a week just to keep in touch of
your [ __ ] no sponsors no
[ __ ] guest no jumping up and down
just to check in with you see where
we're at
make sure everybody's alright but for
right now what the [ __ ] it's Monday
night what'd he do with your life that
so [ __ ] spectacular mmm kick back
smoking juggling uncle Joey I said what
I had to say if you don't like it suck
my dick you do twittering meth flavor
you understand me
slinging dick and giving up bubblegum
it's just 1982 speak of 1982 I'm gonna
tell you another story to piss you off
fracking 1882 I [ __ ] robbed the
jewelry stood you guys know that one
what's the statue of limitations
I don't know suck my dick they did away
with the camera video it said it's over
did you know about that one oh he robbed
a jewelry store yeah that's right so
listen year by year and the creepy
things [ __ ] he thinks and I made good on
him I'm a good friend I'm a good
neighbor again I apologize to my nieces
my nephew's my daughter my wife my dear
friendly Steve someone and many others
who have had my back doing this I
apologize to you for all this [ __ ] but
hey I did it my way [ __ ]
straight out of Hudson County New Jersey
slinging dick and giving our bubble gum
you follow me I don't give a [ __ ] if you
guys want to be on board you be on board
if not move on with your [ __ ] life
I'm gonna keep telling about my life
listen I'm gonna
while comic I've crossed the fence it's
me re and a bunch of other ones tickets
are still on sale and by you people the
more you [ __ ] make a fuss the more
tickets I sell what do you think is
coming out next week cancel joke Diaz
take a chance Columbus did where's
Columbus got no [ __ ] it standing
there like I'm mama Luca ba so that's
what's coming out you want to hate me
I'll [ __ ] make shirts you could buy
him whatever I don't give a [ __ ] you
know me like I told you I live for this
type of [ __ ] so knock it off go on with
your life go snoop up somebody else's
Hasso deserves it and that's it I'm not
gonna let you go yet I don't know the
joint it is smokeless I want to show you
what's in the Bible bo I want to [ __ ]
him give a shout-out to ABX edibles
always having my [ __ ] back and
if you haven't noticed the last six
weeks what happened they accused me of
doing xanax cheap not my wife kicking
the [ __ ] dog
you know this hasn't stopped you know
culprit is taking people's mind and you
have nothing to [ __ ] do so what do
you do you pick scabs I woke up three
weeks ago
they were picking up Mikey Warburg's but
beating up a Chinese guy three years ago
poor Marky Wahlberg ain't bothering
nobody
he goes to church up here you don't
bother nobody you picking on monkey war
bird you're just picking at scabs knock
it off go do push-ups get a [ __ ] life
do something do something stop taking in
[ __ ] scabs dumb [ __ ] anyway
that's it and that's them
let's get this party started yeah it's
Monday night what do you want from me
[ __ ] wanted better alive
[ __ ] Instagram live a couple nights a
week
I don't answer questions I can't see me
no feel I'm throw too good you know I'm
saying me no see so good so there's no
questions to be asked if you want
questions call the New York Times they
got plenty of [ __ ] questions where's
[ __ ] now what's his name
what are you having son he's probably on
this right now that poor [ __ ]
Roman whatever his name is that poor
bastard like I said I feel very very bad
lice at my wife down on Thursday no
listen we're gonna get some meat she
asked me what's going on I go listen in
97 well you [ __ ] forget is I
met my wife at the Comedy Store
she was a waitress since 1998 so she saw
the shenanigans when I told I had to sit
it down I was brokenhearted you know it
was Father's Day weekend I had to tell
and she's like I'm not first of all
wouldn't happened 97 I got no claim on
that [ __ ] I got no claim on that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that was you on your own
but my wife understands where I'm at she
forgave me I was a gentleman like I said
I feel bad for my doorknob they don't
look at an alley [ __ ] what's the name
of a month is [ __ ] nice but [ __ ] it
who gives a [ __ ] you know I'm saying we
live to tell the truth you can't get mad
at somebody for telling the truth that's
what's wrong with society today when
somebody speaks the truth
you [ __ ] you've never heard the
truth cuz you hang out with people that
are amazing and fabulous and know they
don't know nothing about the truth that
telling you what the [ __ ] you want to
hear you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] when
was the last time you really had an
african-american at your house eating
[ __ ] lunch or dinner never what
you're all a bunch of [ __ ] phony
[ __ ] so knock it the [ __ ] off in
my world you gotta come correct or don't
coming on I don't need this [ __ ]
fabulous oh my god I want to see this
amazing guy what am i late talking about
we put our last two legs one leg at a
[ __ ] time you understand me all of us
and that's the way I've always treated
people I know better than you I got a
[ __ ] GED and the only reason why I
got it was because it would lower the
points down when I went to prison
you think you'd be able to understand
and that's it and that's that I hope you
enjoyed it but I hope I made myself
clear that some people again I am I'm
sorry to the church family but at the
same time you guys made my father's day
because you went after these people you
set him straight
you told by my alright you told him
there was times I made you crazy but you
told the truth and that's what I'm here
to do you watch a movie from the 70s
it's not a [ __ ] Barney they made you
cringe The Godfather The Exorcist
Deathwish the rape scene [ __ ] all
these movies made your [ __ ] cringe I
don't make you cringe I'm just telling
you the [ __ ] truth
if you don't want to hear it what can I
tell you but instead of worrying about
some [ __ ] girl that left the store
and contacted me after I did that video
you know she can't think of me in Gmail
or some [ __ ] five years later she's
married she's got three kids she's happy
so you know again sometimes you take a
story and why you telling the comedy
story part of it is exaggeration you
know what I used to have a joke he's
just not cope with my cat did you people
actually believe I started cope with my
cat if you did get the news get the nose
if you really believe that I gave my
coke [ __ ] my cat coke while of it was a
joke but it was an imagination type
thing that you look at the picture of
the coke you know useful look out a
window together that's a joke so please
start making the difference between
jokes and what's real when I tell you a
[ __ ] story of me growing up I'm
telling you I'm using you as a
psychiatrist you know you guys depend on
me and I depend on you so thank you very
much
I love you guys I love the support and
[ __ ] it cancel you got a better chance
to sniffing my [ __ ] [ __ ] in
canceling you understand me it ain't
happening so take that trip somewhere
else go talk to some other guy from some
TV show look at some directing I busted
today for [ __ ] kidnapping and
whatever go talk to him alright I'm just
a [ __ ] outlaw comic I got dates
coming up you want to come and protest
them come on down I'll sell more tickets
the more you keep talking the more the
podcast grows and the more followers I
get so keep [ __ ] acting you dumb
[ __ ] that's all you're doing is
flattening the Fanning the flames now
they want to come and see remember
people don't go to the circus for the
[ __ ] clowns they go for the Tigers
and the [ __ ] lions okay you guys are
the [ __ ] clowns they don't want to
see you [ __ ] no more they don't
want to see you that past you
[ __ ] now they want to see the
guys that got bite into their things the
guys that come on a podcast and talk to
you guys in the heart every week and I'm
thankful for that and I know you
[ __ ] are thankful especially
during this whole corona [ __ ] virus
now we came out every week with mass we
were forced to zoom but we didn't give a
[ __ ] because we're like the [ __ ] the
mailman we got to deliver it that's it
and that's that please please please the
cops are here [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you